I was quite excited when when I was
invited to to apply to be a partner I
participate in a lot of Education a lot
of cost before before I met you and we
usually say if you don't put into
practice what you're paid to do it's
just expensive entertainment so to speak
so very excited because I felt your
passion your enthusiasm and I know that
was going to give me the motivation to
go forward and actually do something
with it I was very nervous when when I
was as absurd as as a partner and
because of the investment and I was
making the decision we've had my wife
knowing and I'm nodding gonna say on
this video how much she was because
that's a conversation to you for you
guys to have with Samuel but so needless
to say I knew that I was going to smash
it and if I needed a motivation to keep
a certain part of my anatomy and in
position I need to go out and earn that
money so I could be debt-free but at
least just from Samuel I've been a
partner with Samuel now for three months
just just in the three months and I'm
flipped seven properties in total I have
a specific goal in terms of income so to
speak which I won't say on that on the
video because it's obviously quite a
personal thing but I'm going to smash
that I am on target of the best year
ever
of being never been a financial advisor
I want to do five properties a month and
that's going to give me the quality of
life that I want and to be able to do
things whereas before there's been too
much months at the end of my paycheck
you got to choice in life and if you're
making it if you sit in there deciding
whether I should be a partner or not you
can do it and you might be successful
and if you don't do it you'll always be
ruin a day what if I died on that where
would a bit you know where would if you
think about two years time where would I
be today how do I actually take him that
the decision to have been a partner two
years ago don't do it don't don't make
not and make the decision make a
decision great thing about being a
partner is that you know we say there's
an expression I love a riding boat what
I write in tide raises all ships and
that's a great thing about being about
being a partner nobody wants to be more
successful than anybody else we want
everybody to be successful and they are
you